okay there we go welcome welcome welcome
everybody welcome to the comma prime
launch party alright so first we're
gonna tweet the live stream just find
our hello
please prime for the win I'm gonna
figure how to delete the old stream and
I don't know we'll deal with that later
no share this one let's check my tweet
looks good yo yo there's no black panda
that's fake
alright guys I didn't really plan too
much for the live stream I did plan this
is what we're launching it is called
comma Prime and it's a good service it's
also an excuse for you to give us annual
recurring revenue which is something we
need in order to make you know Silicon
Valley are happy with us and they could
they could love us if we just became the
kind of company that makes annual
recurring revenue it's not a credit card
it's not a credit card you know what I'm
just gonna post the medium post and you
guys can all follow along just copy and
paste this let me post on Twitter let's
see the card validator I love you every
Twitter's card validator guys there's
card validated space thank you
yeah that looks pretty good ,
I'm launches today exclamation point dad
all right let's make that our pinned
tweet John sorry
Drew's introducing comm Prime okay
so you guys can can link to this and
read it but basically it's got a couple
of cool things one it has an unlimited
data plan meaning you can buy the SIM
card from us and it gives you all the
data you need for your Eon
oh it's unlimited but it is capped to
512 kilobytes of bandwidth well we could
wait for a few more people to get in
here before we get to the next thing but
you know what we're doing it right like
um you know we're we're a social local
mobile company except if you get rid of
the social so we have mobile and in
order to really be mobile what's more
mobile than being a cell phone provider
I'm so it turns out you can be where
we're in Envy and oh we didn't come and
put towers in your local neighborhood
we didn't upset your local housing
hallways and stuff we didn't do that we
we partnered unfortunately contractually
I'm not allowed to say who we partnered
with but it's they're good they're good
don't worry we didn't partner with
anybody crappy I wouldn't do that to you
guys um so it's unlimited data it will
not work in the UK right now it's us
only we're not sure it might work in
Canada in Mexico but we're gonna say us
only but if you buy one in Canada and
Mexico maybe it will work so we have
some new infrastructure you are all out
in 0.6 the queue logs the 512 kilobit
will allow you to update load your
routes in real time so they'll show up
right away in the app should be pretty
cool alright so that's the good thing
right that's a good thing um and just so
you will get this out of the way right
now it's $24 a month so you know $24 a
month if you
some old TechCrunch Disrupt Tom had
always been talking about how it's gonna
be $24 a month well guess what now it's
$24 a month um so you can buy it in the
app , connect but we'll get to all that
in a minute we're gonna talk about the
next perk that you get now this is kind
of the bad one so remember when we
promised unlimited cloud storage well
that was all alive because it turns out
that cloud storage is really expensive
we had free cloud dollars for a while
but the free cloud dollars are running
out so the perks that we can you know
pass onto you are running out too but
basically what this means is you know
you can access all your drives and
Explorer in the app and in Cabana if you
don't have a comma Prime membership you
only get three days one two three but if
you have comma crime you get 14 14 days
of unlimited storage
[Music]
you don't like clouds where's your
privacy bro-bro privacy is dead what
we'll get to privacy actually we have
for the next part is pretty private I
like to think that like read privacy is
dead but right privacy can still
definitely exist um so we we these are
expected things these are expected you
should have expected them from us you
know we got a we got to do it just going
discord so we can we can live discord
while we're live youtubing and all the
things so we're gonna go through a few
more things and then we're gonna go
around the office and ask people what
their opinions are on Kama Prime there's
no black panther guys um no no no but we
have one really cool thing for you guys
um that I think oh yeah disgorge a
comedy guy we have one really cool thing
for you guys that I hope I'm you're
gonna appreciate let's see how our how
our tweets are going yeah you know what
yeah okay cool
okay the next thing is the ssh gateway
so this one i'm gonna show you a little
bit one of the first things we built at
kama was a VPN if you own an eon we
should get a free sim if we sign up for
kama prime so the sims are $20 if you
already own an eon if you're buying eon
today or later you get a free sim but
why do you think i'm gonna mail you guys
all sims you think I'm really gonna do
that and then me with a little envelope
sitting there forever no no no no it's
not ssh with 22 port right because we're
not gonna open we're not going to expose
that ssh to the internet um you can't
really do that right because you're
behind nats what we've built is an SSA
edge gateway it's not a VPN um so to be
clear what the differences are we don't
like like unlike some other companies
that put all the cars on a VPN I think
they moved away from that now but you
kind of don't want to do that right
because then all the phones are on the
same VPN so you don't want to do that
sorry if you're in Europe this is for
the America the US people only I'm not
dealing with all your privacy laws talk
to your local representative to make it
easy you know only punish I'm all for
punishing Google and Facebook but don't
don't punish me you know so no it's a
gateway meaning what it can do is no go
to discord comma dot ai it forwards SSH
through our servers but it's end-to-end
encrypted meaning we can't tap into to
to any of that stuff
it's your private key and the way that
you enter your private key is you enter
your github username right here so this
is gonna be in zero point six point one
on both open file adventure for plus and
it's gonna grant SSH access to the
public keys that are built into your
jail we do not have access to your Yann
no no man in the middle attack if you
guys tell me how to man in the middle
attack this I'll be impressed I thought
about it a bit it seems pretty good our
so our security model is the same as SSH
meaning basically all its real all our
back-end is really doing is exposing the
SSH port on the phone to
yeah it's just like bitcoins encryption
system okay so this is the command
you're gonna use you can go right now to
ssh comedy i i'm gonna go to it right
here that's the stage comedy eye and it
shows you how to set it up so this is
the command we have some scripts to make
it easier but if you want you can just
do this this is the key this is the
dongle ID i press enter and give it a
minute and boom i'm connected to the
Aeon so this is now live on any on and
you'll be able to connect your Aeon just
as easily um who wrote that well do you
want to go do you want to go speaker
globe we got to get to one more thing
and then we can go speak with who wrote
the ssh and then we can answer any
questions you might have about comma
Prime so how do you sign up if you don't
have it right now go on both the iOS and
the Android App Store you can download
it's it's it's if you know what SSH is
you can do it um no it's not Arch Linux
Ubuntu servers high-quality um what this
does is gives you remote access to your
Eon from anywhere in the world so if you
are a comma Prime member you can just
set up a script on your computer so you
can remotely access basically your car
from anywhere in the world um we're
gonna be rolling out a lot of features
in the coming months that use like this
live integration with the car say
something hypothetically we could roll
out is like door unlock from the app or
something like that right I don't know
if that's actually gonna happen but you
could theoretically build features like
that for now we're giving you know are
our tools still really are developer
tools so we're giving developers access
remote start yeah SSH right you see not
now you guys are thinking of course you
know yeah remote access to your car it's
your car that you're getting remote
access to know the EON is never offline
for power saving the EON is always
connected to the cell phone network just
like a normal cell phone right but a lot
of the power saving stuff had nothing to
do with the the radio being on in low
power so the comma Prime is available
for purchase in the app for 24 dollars a
month and remote fuel check absolutely
$24 a month it's only available right
now in the you know
States and if you have an eon currently
you're gonna need a comma sim and you'll
be able to buy that there's a link for
the medium post into comma prime sim for
only oh come on come on you a guy I've
gotta consume more gotta get some more
tweets on this who's not excited about
comma prime let's just post this on the
discord with it with a nice at channel
yeah we love an ad channel you know what
better idea we'll put it in the
announcements channel boom done yeah
that's not what I wanted to do that's
out of this let's just make this the
medium post
oh maybe everyone will click through
that anyway I was not at it no no no no
cancel delete be Oh kitty
I don't even you know when I livestream
normally I have it too you guys can see
my screen you can't even see my screen
right now but let's hope that that
expands nicely so this isn't just court
announcements right here yeah cool sweet
so gamma prime includes the unlimited
cell service we may someday offer a
version that does not know 19 inch
monitors in your car's okay let's go
speak with our app developer Andy who's
done a lot of the work to make comma
Prime a possibility hey Andy you want to
talk to the YouTube ease
let's go peace they still scope peace oh
yeah wait hang on flip the camera so I
can
[Music]
you're really happy about it we're
externalizing the key part of our
infrastructure that we've had for few
years it's really nice to rewrite it in
a way that we know we can share with
with everyone and it's actually really
nice our old VPN used to kill our car
batteries it would wake up the radio all
the time and we think our new design is
going to be much better on that front so
hopefully less trips to the car
dealership to to the Toyota dealership
and in fact the new design uses Athena
which has already been rolled out in
open pilot our couple versions now so I
think we'll be good on the prime only
feature like comma security good you
want anything oh how many people had
VPNs yeah yeah yeah shut it down come on
prime yeah we should do we should do the
cheap comm prime that doesn't include
the data Sunday - we'll see there's a
lot a lot of Europe a lot of Europe was
like is this only for America yeah yeah
we're on the finances you guys should
all buy it we want lots of annual
recurring revenue cool cool
thanks guys
all right let's take a look at the plant
an interlude for the plant want to say a
few words in the scope yeah has worked
hard to make puts the car on the
internet like Internet of Things we
didn't we didn't say Internet of Things
nearly enough and our medium post I'm
gonna edit the categories right now
Mykel watts I'm glad you like it
Willem deep anything oh good yeah no
it's uh this has been a long time in the
making we can't mention we didn't
mention them yeah I think so too
I think yeah I think this is really
important to the future of the company
you know making sure we can provide the
best possible service no matter where
you are and not make you have to go home
and connect to Wi-Fi yeah cool thanks
well a deep any quick comments yes
they're very excited about God I was
look at the plant always a nice plant
guys Harold
do you have any comments about common
prime is it coming to the UK I don't
know if there's enough demand do you
know what if there's enough demand
somehow you can signal that demand to me
we can work hard to try to find a UK
partner what did I know during I know
whose name what's my scam well if we
just want the connectivity know so the
SSH feature only works if you're a comma
Prime member and we're gonna start doing
this with a lot more of the sort of
cloud-based features basically the cloud
costs us money and unless it makes money
we cannot afford the cloud so if you
want the cloud to continue by comma
prime summary the announcement check out
the medium post on twitter well you pay
twenty so you pass twenty four you'll
have a better experience you know we're
really maybe maybe we'll do we'll do
some we'll do some special colors for
people on disk or who have comma Prime
let's see how many SIM cards we sold
let's see if we sold a lot of SIM cards
he's come from a popular product let's
find out
LTE band compatibility don't worry about
that all the Aeons are very compatible
with the comma Prime Network all right
all right how many have we sold so far
zero no no no I'm kidding you've sold
one we sold uh I bet on you guys I bet
on you guys to buy lots of SIM cards go
to the shop right now buy a SIM card
before we run out No
you sign up the SIM cards not free the
SIM cards $20 it's only free for the
people who buy eons from now on we did
sell one Eon though so maybe comma Prime
is sold in neon you guys we really need
to we need to sell things cuz that's
what we do as a company and you guys
need to buy things I think I think
that's how it works you see all these
eons look back to you running out like
that used to be full of eons and like
now it's not full of eons anymore now
it's full of like phones and boxes
you just bought thank you thank you we
are we are gonna be the Android of smart
cars um so yeah sign up today thank you
thank you for age thank you come on get
in here buy them buy them buy them we're
not selling any large monitors for the
cars no that's not happening
no you can't buy them with comma points
unfortunately wait wait you guys bought
I don't see your orders on here no
what's going on guys you got to click
the Buy button you got to click the
checkout button all the way you can't
just add it to the cart that doesn't
make us any money how many users yeah
while the livestream tweet got very
little got very little traction so we're
just gonna delete that I bye tweet and
hopefully people will be excited about
comic rhyme just bought just bought
shout out shout out to to Christian
who's working on the hybrid Corolla did
you actually buy let me check yes I see
your purchase right here excellent thank
you thank you please buy Colin prime
guys we're not getting interviewed by
anybody we're just rolling out the
products it really is a great product it
makes you eat a lot better it's $20 for
the SIM card and then $24 per month you
know it's it's it's a it's a good deal
you should buy comma Prime if you're in
Indonesia don't buy the SIM card it will
not work for you
is it a data it's an unlimited data
service what even is phone mean today oh
you buy on that I think GT mobile
cyclones that make sense yeah no it's
very reasonable you can also tether you
know you can your yon can serve as a
hotspot you can tether you can connect
other devices through this it's
unlimited some limits you guys can use
all the data you want if the price rises
in the future will you be grandfathered
in
perhaps we can certainly work out things
like that especially as we start to add
some real perks to calm a crime this is
just the beginning no I'm not selling a
stop asking for the big monitor we're
not doing any big monitors what is it
check out the medium posts I'm gonna
link the medium post right here in the
YouTube comments
while you want I can find it from
Twitter but I deleted the livestream
post so that's too bad yeah you guys can
post attacker nice we're not using arch
linux stop with the monitor I have to
figure out it delete this one
this shouldn't be a thing edit video
[Music]
how do I do we I don't know okay all
right that's that's that's mostly what
we're talking about today for comm prime
any yeah phone sourcing we're good we're
running on Windows nah we're running on
Linux everything here is on Linux
let me get a link to the medium post
that I can post right here in the
YouTube
perfect
well you can certainly do both yeah
updates put OTA updates you know I know
it's it's for I think a car is like a an
internet-connected device now it really
is an internet-connected device would
call a prime cool iot that's right oh
I'm gonna Oliver's gonna change the I
was gonna change the things on the
medium post to include the Internet of
Things story tag yeah this is a way to
problem cool guys thank you for joining
today's live stream that was today's
project announcement comma Prime it's
available at shop comma dot a I can the
uplink handled and how long will it take
well so we've moved to a we've moved to
a queue logs which mean we upload a
really small amount of data that
describes your route pretty well and
that can keep up in real time that's
about a hundred K per second so at 512
bandwidth should keep it up no problem
um does it work in Canada maybe it may
work in Canada in Mexico
we're not sure yet if you try it then
let us know how it works and if it works
well then we'll advertise that it works
in Canada and Mexico as well it's a good
way to it's a good way to get an
unlimited data plan it it shows if you
guys buy it
it shows that there's demand for these
features and then we'll put more effort
into developing even more features like
you know like we're talking before about
the remote door unlocks engine start we
can do things also like comma security
say somebody caps on the hood of your
car you can send you a ping your text
phone right if come on if al cam can
exist as a company doing only this and
we can roll it out with an OTA update so
I'm talking about
cool dog too I'm super happy I love when
people buy things at shop comedy i yes
sentry mode we call it comma security
right yes sentry mode his security right
is that the feature you all want a
bullet
see how many people buy it no it can't
cure your depression this isn't that
kind of AD the truth is no product is
gonna have any influence on your
happiness it just might make your life a
little bit better and a little bit more
convenient
yes entry mode right no remote drive
remote a/c perhaps I mean this is all
open source stuff right so you'll be
able once you get in to add whatever you
want to your your own pilot or ship for
plus vote with your credit card I like
that I like that this is gonna be a
30-minute live stream so we got four
more minutes to go does it do where's my
park stolen car absolutely that's
already live today in the kama connect
app I'm sorry your card got declined
that sounds like something you need to
take up with your bank
yeah live stream capability that's the
kind of stuff that can be rolled out
look if I look at the bills if I look at
the bills and I'm like man we're making
dirty grand a month annual recurring
revenue on common prime then I'm very
interested in writing all those features
for you because let's see actually know
what if we can get up to ten grand a
month for caring revenue I can hire a
full-time developer to write features
for you
also comma connect app you know make
sure we're gonna be aggressive about
fixing all bugs yeah you can track other
people using your car absolutely please
use it at eclis but that's not my
problem we just write software gets hot
starts the car to cool off yeah it turns
on the a/c can the panteon read obd
codes for check engine lights of course
it can but you got to write the software
you'll code for food well you know what
I'll do one better just submit pull
requests to explore and Cabana making
them fast and perform and to not be very
happy with you is SSH open source of
course it is it's called OpenSSH check
neo ask the operating system
distribution we have tells you what
version it is you can find every line of
the code in there which cars will get
priority you know which cars get
priority Honda's in Toyotas $30 shipping
to Canada yeah I mean that's the
International shipping charge I don't
know what to tell you why don't you
order a panda while you're at it too
Thank you Thank You Ethan each dub um I
can't read YouTube's comments are
nowhere near as good as periscopes
comments but their stream quality is
just so much better
you bought kama prime congratulations
thank you for buying kama prime you are
making it possible for us to develop
features for everybody everybody else
because the money from kala prime will
go straight into kama prime features
let's see how many how many common
crimes who sold oh oh we got we got
we're up 200 we got actually a lot
oh they're rolling in now we got five we
got five thank you all very much
we got five who we got one Aeon if you
could keep the Aeon in your car 24/7 so
we keep our eons in the car 24/7 I
understand that in some places maybe the
temperature doesn't allow this but I
think if you park it out of the Sun it's
gonna be fine no matter what we've made
great strides in the amount of power
that yun uses who shouldn't kill your
car battery unless you leave your car
for over a week so that's pretty good
comma crime uses like really no more
battery in San Diego you've killed too
we have all our cars with the Aeons in
them Texas yeah if you leave it in the
Sun yeah don't leave your cars in the
Sun that's not good for your cars anyway
the batteries the batteries good um so
we we leave the Aeons used to kill our
car in a weekend but we did a lot to
lower power consumption we've removed
OpenVPN off of our phones and now the
battery life is more than a week so you
should be pretty good you can make a
tinfoil you can make a sunshade I mean
people have those for their cars too for
a reason you know it's good to keep your
whole car cool battery list Eon with USB
power over the comma power the battery
is less of a big deal than you guys
think we moved to San Diego a couple of
months ago life's a lot better down here
as that's a scam yeah any last questions
about comma Prime now across that's cool
are you telling me we have one more
order you
no I can't I delete it off Twitter this
is private YouTube jam yeah I tried to
look and I couldn't see it yeah yeah
yeah that's kind of the medium post on
Twitter this YouTube thought some people
find it turns out these don't convert
that one medium close to media post
convert very well yes we've started to
track analytics because we're gonna be a
real company and uh where is your one
you don't like your lane curves show you
the executive bathroom all right yeah
well go to the bathroom you go to the
bathroom on stream oh this is the comi I
stream if it was my twitch we could do
that no oh what science oh yeah okay I
don't want to know about that let's see
how many let's see how many how many
things we sold did we sell a lot I would
show you guys this screen but it has
everybody's names on it so we're not
gonna do that
hey privacy great again I mean I don't
want access to your device because it's
just a liability for me oh my gosh oh so
many of you sold eight we've sold eight
all right should we keep the stream
going until I can't count how many of
you sold on my fingers oh this is pretty
good guys
I bet hi we have an internal like office
little betting pool to see how many are
gonna be sold
I bet thirty-two so you guys don't let
me down come on everyone by comma prime
today's the day to buy it you'll get
that SIM card in the mail you're gonna
love it
we got eight so far let's just get three
more let's keep the stream going until
we get three more buys Oh check this out
guys look at how much common prime we
have in stock
four-twenty so you only need to buy 24
mo no no we just gonna sell 11 we've
sold a it so far they're pretty good it
was a little bit slow at first but I'm
glad you guys are coming around to see
all the benefits of that kama prime can
offer you the sim cards only $20 to get
started I'm not signing anybody's ,
Prime we're not doing that walks are
what's kama prime check out the medium
post kama prime is our new $24 a month
unlimited data service it's not just
unlimited data it provides more than
four times as much cloud storage as as
the newly nerfed cloud storage without
kama Prime it provides SSH to remotely
access your Aeon in a very secure way
such that we do not have access to your
Aeon only you with your private key no
you can't you have to get a comma sim
which is the SIM cards that we sell how
many aeons sold last month a bit over
100 is this we're not actually allowed
to say contractually the name of who
said mobile network partner provider
might be but it is a good one and if you
you know think a little bit maybe you
can you can you guys can solve the
mystery
Thanks walks or no that's a weird
question Al's dee sign some of the sims
to sell them faster known and I don't
know we're not doing any of that no it's
not Verizon it's a mystery but it's a
good one don't worry it's not like
sprint or 18 to you or anything like
that
alright we got we got us out we're still
at eight guys was still at eight come on
I'm not signing them now maybe maybe
we'll just leave it a day maybe we'll
just leave you today I'm not licking any
other sim stop that guys
oh man right now we're starting to get
some reach on Twitter good good much
better chance for more than three gigs a
month I think if you do it and do that
math again she'll be able to do quite a
bit more
you've just just fallen high refresh it
again oh oh it just fills another one
that's nine guys that's nine that's mine
kama primes no we don't have any
marketing people we have me who does
live streams occasionally we don't
really do that we do so we have we have
we have a great designer and like we
design sales right sales are designed
they're not marketed yeah we are real
yeah it's a lot when three gigs and
there's there actually no cap you can
upload as much as you want
make sure that I don't think it ever I
don't think it throttles you we've tried
I don't think it's one point three
terabytes either I think that's
aggressive as well I think I think when
you do the math it's somewhere in like
the 30 gigabyte range let me let me let
me do the math out sorry I can't sorry I
can't show you this dream this screen
but I just don't have a good way to do
it but okay so it's 512 kilobits per
second times 60 that's per minute time
60.0 times 24 times 30 and that is of
course kilobits not kilobyte so we're
gonna divide that by eight I'm gonna say
kilobits kilo by data bytes
so if I did the math right it's that
nights it's 512 kilobyte 60 minutes 60
60 seconds per minute 60 minutes per
hour 24 hours per day 30 days per month
divided by 8 because it's bites not
vents kilobytes equals hundred twenty
hundred thirty-six five gigabytes so
that's theoretically possible but you
get you get less than that right but
like really you don't need that much
um kanikama prime symbol used as a
hotspot not in an eon no they only work
with eons uh okay google yeah yeah yeah
dance listen did it's a better way than
uh than I did um yeah that Terra was was
those you're not going we're not going
Terra big here
he owns use about I think I think it's
about like no contract cancel anytime
it's month-to-month $24.00 no roaming
charges as far as I know we definitely
won't charge you more than twenty four
dollars a month
the Eon can be used as a hotspot my face
is red a little hot in here let's see
how many more sales we have we have
sales sales
I love sales
only nine I'm pretty happy with knowing
guys
ma'am maps are never gonna happen maps
are a dumb idea and get into why maps
are dumb idea on some other live stream
may consider signing up the inside PR
gets merged we should merge the inside
PR change the AC yeah I'm happy with
nine guys nine is pretty good the sales
are gonna trickle in all day thank you
all for watching this official , prime
launch party that's a pretty good deal
are you gonna order one now oh wait I'm
gonna hang on if you're gonna order one
now I'm gonna hang on we'll get to ten
zero six one goes live later today I
think to beta and then yeah no maps are
stupid you know what I will show you
guys something cool I will show you guys
something cool
since all 113 of you stuck with me
through this live stream but actually
only if we buy more stuff you got to buy
more stuff
yes look here see the red light see the
green light see how when it's red it's
like slow down see you when it's green
it's like go ahead yeah so secret Maps
is dead with the point of a grey panda
um so if you have a grey Pandit your
data is included in the training set so
it'll work better in your area most
likely good then there's no black Panda
can be on autopilot work in France maybe
is the stuff you learn in a research
upstream almost while working on it oh
oh you're gonna buy one too
are we actually gonna get to 11 I'm so
happy when we get to the number I say
we're gonna get to gonna buy a new car
soon so hold on if you do buy a neon
today by the way the SIM card is
included for free I did tell you all
that eons were appreciating assets we
didn't get to ten yet we're still at
nine I did tell you all that eons are
appreciating assets so future eons are
gonna include a free free
free Kyle prime SIM card just for you
guys we got it we got to get it we gotta
get I feel like we can do it guys I feel
like we could do it yeah buy a panda
while you're at it - you don't want just
buy more stuff I mean the stores open
for everything guys come to the
beautiful comma a I store it's open for
everything you're number ten all right
all right let's let's refresh this and
see if this guy's actually telling the
truth grd no no we don't have any
beanies anymore those are sold out
oh yeah Jared D is telling the truth he
really did buy us in we have one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
can we get two eleven can we get two
eleven who else wants to buy a sim you
won't regret it you'll love your new ,
prime get out your wallets guys it's 20
bucks but don't buy it if you're not
gonna use it save the common crime Sims
to people who are gonna use it
oh hold up Bob Cammack is buying oh yeah
you're gonna be number 11 that's cool
I'm super happy when we get to I don't
have any more traffic light detection
that's the only one I have not merely
have one common insurance maybe
eventually right yeah the affiliate
program it didn't it didn't increase
sales unless we cancelled it wouldn't
try other things like that maybe in the
future it is only for the u.s. I'm sorry
I'm sorry I wish our partner had more I
can't even know how much I could say I
wish they were all everywhere they might
be in Canada and Mexico we don't really
know I'm looking up coverage map of
unnamed provider perfect oh yeah oh is
that 11 is that 11 did you just buy 11
just go no no no we're still 10 just got
in what did you miss to that I the video
contest was a good deal we could do the
video contest again and I'll spend more
time judging it I feel like I was too
quick on the last time judging the video
contest yeah we don't do live streams
that often only now you missed
everything so I'm holding up for one
more person who's gonna get it
what was the video contest thousand
bucks who can make the best dolphin
pilot video yeah I think it does work in
Mexico and Canada show you something fun
in the office our go to date aside
oh my mom just texted me I'm going I'm
going back to Jersey more I'm using
Ubuntu 1604 would you do the video
contest no I don't know about Iran
alright guys welcome to the home the
data center
cool
this is where all the models get trained
have you wondered why the models have
gotten so good lately it's because the
data is so big got some cars in here the
Prius Corolla it's all the way back
there
Oh Michael Watts ordered Michael Watts
ordered oh this is exciting yeah we have
zi8 40s for everybody at the office that
guy was telling the truth I don't know
if you want me to say your name publicly
I forget if your name is in your
username
we don't want out anybody we care deeply
about some kinds of privacy so yeah
there's that we just reached 11 sales
guys I'm so happy that you guys could
get me to 11 you're all incredible scope
ease and I want you to go out every day
and remember all Brad's buying right now
all we're gonna get to 12 well that's
even more than 11 that's crazy that's
crazy that's so many sales I'm super
happy that you guys are buying these
because every comic Prime subscription
that we sell increases the likelihood
that we're gonna hire a full-time
developer to write come prime features
review I'm sorry I have to go we reached
11 we reached 11 but I'm glad we made it
there you guys got a 45 minute stream we
have to we had to get through those last
few sales but since we made it that's
all I have to say today only $24 a month
$20 for the sim included free with all
new Aeons you'll be able to activate
comma Prime directly from your comic
Connect app available for iOS and
Android the comic connect app is free if
you have a neon already download it
you're gonna have a great time it's got
a lot of five-star reviews let's keep it
that way if you have something bad to
say tell us we'll fix it and leave us a
good review thank you very much bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye YouTube iscope peace
bye